the midterms are over or are they over
in the last two Senate races we thought
we'll go into the GOP they seem to win
an election night I'm talking about
Florida I'm talking about Arizona
thousands of uncounted ballots keep
popping up though mostly in the
Democratic leading areas what is going
on here and why are these elections
still up in the air Senator Marco
Rubio's had it he's tweeted about it
saying this Democrat lawyers are
descending on Florida they've been very
clear they aren't there to make sure
that every vote is counted they are here
to change the results of the election
and Broward County is where they plan to
do it Senator Marco Rubio joins us right
now
senator what makes you think that their
words they held a press conference and
said that we're not here to just have a
recount we're here to win and look we
have procedures in the law for clothes
selections and recounts I have no
problem with any of that I have no
problem with anyone availing themselves
of what the law allows them to do here's
my problem my problem is this is focused
on two counties and in particular one
County so let me use an example Bay
County Florida where Panama City is was
hit by a cat affort got category 4
hurricane about four weeks to the day of
this election they were without power
you guys covered all this they did all
their ballots at a 52 percent return
rate you know a 52 percent turnout
despite the hurricane they did all her
ballots submitted them on time they were
done basically on election night early
the following morning very early Broward
County 48 hours later is still counting
and they didn't have a category 4
hurricane and it's not the first time
that they do this problem number one
problem number two is we don't know how
many votes they have and neither do they
either they don't know or they won't
tell anybody how many ballots are left
to count you know and so forth and so
it's concerning when you go to sleep at
3:00 a.m. on Wednesday morning after the
election and for example Rick Scott is
up by 60,000 votes fifty-four thousand
votes whatever it was today is at 17,000
and the only counties that are still
reporting are Palm Beach and and and
Broward right who will have a history by
the way on these things you know Broward
County lost a lawsuit to the Republican
Party a while back because they were
opening up absentee ballots and
beginning to count them before they were
supposed to okay Broward County in
August this year in Broward County
mysteriously or I should to say let me
I use that term 5000 mail ballots
appeared it all of a sudden at 7:00 p.m.
on Tuesday night of the election that it
actually grew to 9,000 when they were
done counting those a school board race
that involved Ryan petty one of the
parkland fathers that was challenging a
school board member
suddenly the incumbent was able to
barely but she did avoid a runoff a
judge race flipped at a 400 vote margin
after these 9,000 votes appeared so this
is a pattern of at a minimum and
competence and it's embarrassing to the
state voters deserve better this is not
even a partisan thing well this is a
county that apparently cannot count
votes as well as the county that just
got wiped out by a hurricane no matter
what happens you have a sitting governor
up for this election and Marco Rubio
you've been there he's just straighten
this out Brenda Snipes illegally
destroyed ballots in 2016
she's still in charge now they can't
count the ballots they're supposed to
have it up 30 minutes after elections
closes it's still not done so I just
talked to governor Scott's office he has
a presser tonight and he says they could
they understand there's got to be a
recount an automatic recount first by
Machine if it's still closed then by
hand now we understand that Andrew
Gilliam says I'm look like he is going
to re retract his concession and he's
going to look for a recount there as the
votes beginning to close as well yeah
look the recount is fine the law
provides for that in the case of the
governor's race and Gilliam and the
Santis they're going to take the ballots
and feed them back in the machine and
make sure the machine is accurately
reflecting them in the case of the
Senate campaign they're gonna manually
recount these ballots and what that
means is they're only going to manually
recount under votes and over votes
meaning ballots that voted for more than
one candidate or ballots that did not
vote for any candidate and they're gonna
look at it and see was there a marking
that that showed a voters intent now it
has to be consistent throughout the
ballot so if you put an X in the circle
you got to have put an X in all the
circles you can't just do it for one
race but that's where the lawyers get
involved that's where the fights begin
to happen and that's where we have seen
races in the past suddenly turn my
problem is if this was something we're
seeing in multiple counties it's in one
County and it happens to be a very
democratic County look people have a
right to be concerned about it senator
real quick mark Elias is coming in he's
a Clinton attorney and guess what works
for Perkins cuy and guess what they
hired fusion gps who hired Christopher
Steve
we're back in the dossier conversation
mark Elias is back in our lives as a
country the Clinton lawyers are here and
they're going to start putting a lawsuit
together that the Senate vote the punch
for the Senate was way on the bottom of
the ballot separate making it hard for
people to vote so they're gonna
challenge this legally along with the
recounts along with the ballots we might
have another mess in Florida but you're
least standing up ahead of time instead
of talking about it in the aftermath
crazy Senator Marco Rubio thanks so much
thank you